(applaudissements)
- Il y a des discoursqui marqqu,
même s'ils nous parviennent
de loin, à travers un écran.
(applaudissements)
devenu héros de l'Ukraine
et des d occidentales,
est apparu peu avant midi
d'un endroit gardé secret.
(&(@"<$é<W und@salle comble,
pour interpeller directement
les Canadiens. "Pouvez "Pouvez ,
demande-t-il, qu'à 4 h du matin,
chacun d'entre vous commence
à entendre des bombes,
des expl
"Pouvez-vous concevoir
qu'une armée établisse un siège
autour de Vancouver et que touss
à l'intérieur de la ville?
C'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment à Marioupol",
Pour le président Zelensky,
le Canada doit en faire plus
et ça inclut l'imposition
d'une zone d'exclunne
au-dessus du pays.
n de missiles de plus
doivent tomber sur nos villes
avant que vous ne preniez
aux parlementaires.
(applaudissements)
Des parlementaires qui ont
du président...
- Un dirigeant courageux
et exceptionnel.
- Votre courage nous inspire.
n'ont pas voulu s'engager
à abattre les avions russes
qui pénètrent dans l'espace
ukrainien.
des Affaires étrangères
- L'objectif est de
ne pas déclarer un conflit
international, donc
- Seuls les conservateurs
ont ouvert la port
mais pour protéger le ciel
au-dessus des routes empruntées
leur pays.
LUC BERTHOLD, chef adjoint d
l'opposition officielle, Ottawa
- On demande aux alliés
de prendre les moy,
on puisse protéger les corridors
humanitaires.
- Une démarche qui pourrait
mener à une escalade,
croit leANCHET,
chef, Bloc québécois
- C'est qu'on ne peut
pas se permettre de prendre.
Je ne suis pas prêt à me
opposition pour demander
quelque chose qui semblerait,
ade-ci, irresponsable.
- Yves-François Blanchet demande
toutefois au gouvernementdans l.
Des annonces s'en viennent,prom.
- Certainement, notre objectif
est de pouvoir justement
Donc, les conversations ont lieu
et on va pouvoir en dire plus
sous peu.
- C'est juste trop long.
- Avant que Volodymyr Zelensky
ne s'adresse au Parlement
canadien, Vladimir Poutine
avait déjà préparé sa réplique.
Justin Trudeau, Mélanie Joly
les députés aux Communes sont
dorénava
in,
Radio-Canada, Ottawa.
(déflagrations)
alors que Kiev dormait.
Encore une fois, des immeubles
résidentiels ont été visés
par les tirs russes.
"J'ai été réveillé par le bruit
de l'explosion, dit ce jeune
été de me dire : Tout va bien!
Je suis encore vivant!"des pers,
des blessés, des morts.
Et malgré la cruauté de
ces atta des civils,les momelest
les moments de bravoure.
L'intensification des tirs a aa
ville a décréter un couvre-feu.
"Nous vivons des
difficil
Pour votre sécurité, je vous
demande à l'abrià l'abrià l'abri
pour les 36 prochaines heures."
Peut-être dans l'espoird'entra,
le président ukrainien
a de son côté arer l'OTAN.que ss
partenaires qui nous aident"
a-t-il déclaré. La situation ese
dans plusieurs régions du pays.
L'armée russe affirme avoir
de Kharkov et causé des dommages
importan
ukrainienne.
"Je ne comprends pas tout,
dit cette fillette, mais
je suis contente d'être ici,
dans une école normale."
Une façon de reprendre
le fil d'une vie brisée,
un jour à la fois. Ici Lis Ici ,
Radio-Canada, Mon